sixteen months ago they were being
billed as the Fab Four looking forward
to working together on their charity
projects we really could make a far
bigger impact together we're really
looking forward to working as a parent
as a for going forward now Harry and
Megan have split from the royal
foundation leaving it in William and
Kate's hands in a statement the palace
said the duke and duchess of sussex will
establish their own new charitable
foundation with transitional operating
support from the royal foundation these
changes are designed to best complement
the work and responsibilities of their
royal highnesses as they prepare for
their future roles and to better align
their charitable activity with their new
households the separation is being put
down to the fact that the brothers
facing very divergent roles in the
future we have always known that one day
William will be king and Harry has a
much less defined role within the royal
family and unfortunately for the palace
that does play into those rumors of a
rift and questions about what exactly
has been going on behind closed doors
over the last 18 months the foundation
was originally set up by William and
Harry when they were in their 20s and
has had huge successes
[Applause]
the charitable team gained a new member
when Megan married Harry despite
attempts to show a united front at
Christmas rumors have persisted that the
couples and especially the brothers
aren't always seeing eye-to-eye given
the stories we've heard coming out of
Kensington Palace given the fact that
Harry and Megan have moved out of the
palace that they've split the households
I think this actually did follow as
night the day we don't know exactly what
Harry and Megan's own foundation will
look like or focus on but it is
inevitable the Invictus games will be
part of it even though the Sussex is and
the Cambridge's are now operating as
separate households we are told they
will still work together Rhiannon Mills
Sky News at Buckingham Palace